I want you to meet the drew crew mega make-over team.
Please welcome friend of the show and celebrity hairstylist,
Chris Appleton!
(crowd cheering)
Can you believe it?
New people! Amazing! Love it!
Oh my gosh! I'm so happy to be with Chris.
Oh, you work with Jennifer Lopez, Kim Kardashian...
A few people in Hollywood,
but I'm here today to make over real women,
which is why I love, this is where it all started,
for me, like making real women look and feel great.
So it's gonna be a good one.
All right. Now we're gonna bring in
the founder of Harlem's fashion row.
It's also friend of the show, Brandice Daniel.
(crowd applause)
Welcome back!
So excited to be here.
You know, I have just been cyber-stalking you so much
because I just love your prolificness
and I've such deep admiration for you.
And I'm just so glad that you're a part of today.
I'm so excited to be a part of the today.
The women are amazing. Oh my God!
All right. We also have beauty expert extraordinaire,
my very dear friend, friend of the show
and co-founder of Milk makeup.
It's Zanna Roberts Rassi.
(loud applause)
How fun is this?
I mean, we've all done the show together before
but never like this.
Are we really doing 25 people?
Zanna,
This is mega.
You're just one of my idols in this department.
Oh my gosh well, that means so much coming from you,
because you were mine.
Also, I am so proud to bring to the stage
Instagram sensations, the most fashionable couple I know.
It's The Young Emperors!
Nelson Tiberghien and Isabelle Chaput!
(crowd cheer)
Tell everybody why you do what you do.
Because we were in love mainly. And we chose that.
We were in a team, you know, in life and in our work.
Well, I just think again what you put out into the world,
It's like you put fragrance in the air.
Well, that's so beautiful Drew.
It's true.
It's absolutely true. Okay. Zanna and The Young Emperors
are going to head backstage and get to work.
So excited!
Okay.
Thanks love!
(everyone cheering)
And Brandice we're gonna work with you in just a minute.
Okay.
But Chris you're up first. Okay. All right.
Let's get started because the biggest beauty questions
that we've ever been asked are going to be answered today
and let's ask our first beautiful woman, Marianna.
(applause)
All right, Marianna, what is your beauty question?
Okay, with the pandemic I've been nervous about
going back to salons and now my hair has gotten really long,
really limp, really dry. And I'd love to try bangs too,
but that's like high maintenance
and I don't want anything that takes a long time to style.
What are my options here?
I think for me and for you, I think what would really work
is like the curtain bang, sorta trend,
which is really big right now
because it frames the face beautifully.
It's called curtain bangs cuz they basically are
face framing layers that sit around the face.
But what's nice about them is it just kind of closes,
you know the forehead a little bit.
Once again, Chris, your instincts are brilliant.
I'm not surprised. Marianna are you ready?
I'm ready.
Let's do this.
All right, let's take those bangs to the next bubble.
All right, here we go.
All right. The next question, a burning beauty question
that's going to get answered with expertise advice
comes from Tina, take a look.
I love wearing jeans. I want to level up my denim.
Can you help me dress up a jeans look?
(applause)
So Brandice, how common is this question,
especially these days?
So often we think that jeans are just casual, right?
Just for going up to pick up the kids from school,
but you can really dress jeans up.
You can wear a blazer with it and it's so great
because you can take jeans from like a work day
and then you can go out with your friends
and have cocktails and have a good time.
So they're so transitional.
All right. Well, Tina's here with her new look
and here's a photo of Tina in her jeans before
and let's see her now.
(loud applause)
All right! Tina, what do you think
and more importantly, how do you feel?
I feel so comfortable and put together.
Everybody wants the perfect pair of jeans
and they styled it amazing.
Now Brandice any tips with this outfit
that not only are we looking and liking,
but that we can take away for ourselves.
Yeah, absolutely. So the white shirt is underrated.
It is so underrated.
And then we put on like a kitten heel with it
and she looks incredible, like she actually looks like
the person that she is inside, right.
(applause)
Thank you so much.
Thank you Brandice and Tina.
All right, now we're going to go right over to Chris
and Marianna and check out her reveal of the curtain bang.
Here we are. No edits. Keeping things around.
I love it!
All right guys. So you can see,
I'm just going to put a little bit of texturizing spray,
but you can see we've not actually done anything else
to the rest of the hair. So this face framing here,
I just think softens the forehead.
I think a quick transformation without doing,
you know, an awful lot of work.
You've not seen it yet.
No.
(nervous laughter)
What do you guys think?
(crowd applause)
Should we do the reveal?
I am freaking out. Okay,
do you want to see what you look like cuz I'm freaking out?
Absolutely.
All right, Chris, do you want to turn her around?
All right. One. Two. Three.
(gasp) I love it!
How do you feel?
I love it, Oh my God! I love it so much!
It feels kind of just like soft, effortless, natural.
Will you show her how it looks like
with the hair up too in the mirror, Chris?
Yes, you ready? Let's go.
I gotta tell you too,
like I get really attached to my hair,
cuz I too tried every hair under the sun.
Everything, like no hair, every color hair, perms.
Don't ever cut bangs with a Cal look
and get a perm on the same day.
I have never had a bigger mental breakdown in my life.
And this is making me rethink my hair.
(crowd applause)
Thanks, Marianna. I hope you're happy.
I'm so happy. Thank you so much.
Thank you, Marianna.
(upbeat outro music)